Joe Biden was Barack Obama's right-hand
man a tactile familiar politician who's
now staring a very different kind of
emotion a second woman has come forward
to accuse him of inappropriate touching
back in 2009 he walked up to me and
wrapped his hands around my face like
that and pulled me in and started
rubbing noses with me and it wasn't you
know like an Eskimo kiss or and then
stop it was for like a good 15 seconds
and I remember thinking is he gonna kiss
me her claim has echos of another recent
allegation made by Nevada politician
Lucy Flores I felt him get closer he
leaned in and was like right behind me
on my body and he leans down smells my
hair and then plants this big long kiss
on the top of my head those
uncomfortable stories come as the former
vice president eyes a possible 20/20 bit
in a statement he said in many years on
the campaign trail and in public life
I've offered countless handshakes hugs
expression of affection support and
comfort not once never did I believe I
acted inappropriately if it is suggested
I did so I will listen respectfully but
it was never my intention the climate
and conversation has changed though in
his colleagues know it I think that it's
important for the vice president others
to understand is it isn't what you
intended it's how it was received and
that's generally about it communication
in general the debate has made this
infamous interaction go viral but
Stephanie Carter the wife of the then
defence secretary insists it was just a
close friend helping someone get through
a big day Biden's big day may be yet to
come and it could well be defined by his
ability to embrace a fresh approach
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington